مرحبا انا خالص لان الحاجات كتير من غير
ما لها فلوس على طول بتعلم حاجات توديها
فلوس عشان اعلمها وصلت المرحله وصلت شويه
ان انا
بعد كده
ولقيت ان انا
دوت المرتب
اربعه وكمان شغل اسهل
[موسيقى]
كامل سنه
الشغل دوت علشان ابقى نفسي شويه
بحب
الاولاني
ولقيت
[موسيقى]
طب انا بقى
اللي هو
الاكل وطول الوقت للناس
اي حاجه
[موسيقى]
وراح قال لي
نظام كده احلى
خلصنا رحنا
اول يوم على الفيديو دوت
اي حاجه
[موسيقى]
ايوه
نفس المجال
الكرسي بتاع الهندسه كده لو
بصي انا كنت عايز اروح الشغل عندي طب بص
جنبي لقيت اللي جنبي
اكبر منه 10 سنين احنا
قاعدين
كده انا بعد 10 سنين
انا
يعني
الموظف
فيهم عشر دقايق
في الناس اللي بتعمل حاجات
يبقى عنده احداث كتير
[موسيقى]
هل انا مجرد شخص
عايز الحياه المستقره المريحه
انا برضو
اللي بتحافظ انا مش كده على فكره لان هو
خلاص هو مش لازم حاجات معينه وفي نفس
الوقت بيبقى عنده وقت شويه وما عندهم
خلاص ايه اللي حصل
فهتلاقي ده مش لازم نجحت كله يبقى نجاح
مادي او نجاح ممكن نجاحك
احسن صاحب احسن اخ انجح اب انجح اب انت
اللي بتختار انت عايز تنجح فين هو الوسط
لحد
يقول حاجه كويسه في وقت فراغ نفسه
انا
مش حابب الرجال انا حابب
اقول
له
كلنا مش
ازاي
[موسيقى]
ما ينفعش اقعد
شهرين
كل شهر بتطلع
كل شهر هتخليني معرفش اعيش الشهر ده ليه
ما اخدهاش بس غير الفرصه
ومش حابب فكره الوظيفه حابب فكره
خالص ودي بقى نتكلم على شركه كريم في ناس
بتشوف اللي هو الكليه ملهاش لازمه
انت ضيعت تسع سنين من حياتك وهتسيبهم
وتروح كريم وانا شغال
قصص
يعني مثلا هندسه متعلم حاجه تحلل مشاكل
مثلا كليه تانيه بتعلمك ازاي تحل اي علم
في حياتك حتى لو مش مفيده على ارض الواقع
هو مفيد
اي حاجه حتى المعلومه اللي بتسمع حتى وانت
ممكن الكلام كله
لا يعتقد بيشتري اي خدمه
اديني حته اي حاجه اشتريه وانا ما كنت
قعدت سنتين او الاربع سنين اللي انا
عمري الشخصيه اللي عارفه اتحرك
شوف انا اي حد يقول لي انا
بحاجه او ان انا
تشتغل عند حد فيهم عشان
[موسيقى]
الكليه او الجامعه او الدراسه او اي
فرصه
خلينا
خلاص احنا
بس انا حاليا معيش حاجه على ارض الوا
قع
بتعامل مع الكيوز
[موسيقى]
انا لغايه دلوقتي مش حاسس ان انا
في حاجه ناجحه او حاجه
لكن لما تيجي نعمل حاجه على الوضع
اول ما فيها حتى لو انت
يعني ما تستناش حاجه غير اللي تكون متحركه
يعني ما تقولش انا لما يجيلي انا لما يبقى
معايا فلوس انا هبدا
معي الصوت
طالما وقفنا شيء من بره
احنا ساعتها
المشروع انا نفسي اعمل ايه عملنا على
عشان تعرف تمشي
وندوق كل مرحله
امسح يا باشا المكان اللي انت بتعمله فيه
اطبخ انت ما فيش حاجه تعملها عشان لما يجي
حد يشتغل عندك ويقول لك ما فيش حاجه
وكذا وكذا عشان غلط لان احنا ساعات الناس
اللي عندنا عشان احنا ما ضربناش ان هم سهل
طيب المهم
الحمد لله ادينا عمالين
وكلها
انا كنت
انا وانا جوه المشكله شايفه
لما بحاول اخرج بره
الناس عندي يعني مثلا انا بدرس دلوقتي
وانا بحكي لهم
كل يوم يا اما هيحصل لي الجريلات تولع
الكهرباء تفصل مفاجاه وانت في عز الشغل
خلاص انا
انت بتمر بخبرات
سنين في شهر الناس على يومهم مثلا
ليه انت الجامعات وده اللي انا اكتشفته من
كل حاجه لما واقف يختار الحياه مش هاديه
بيجمع حضرتك لان كل حياتك كل ما تبرم قلت
تلاقي ناس كبيره
[موسيقى]
كلها
اصلا
يعني
فتره طريق طب ازاي ان انت
انا بالنسبه لي مشكله
قالوا لي
في الطريق هو مفتاح كل
يعني انا مش لازم اكون بشوف النتيجه فوريه
مش معنى اللي انا صليته النهارده ان
الدنيا تبقى حلوه
بعمل
كله ما يحصل لي
انا عملت طب هي ليه ما بقت حلوه طب ما انا
ذاكرت ليه ما بقتش
اصلا
يا رب الدنيا تبقى حلوه يا رب على الدنيا
وهي وحشه يا رب يخلينا نتقبل وانا اصلا مش
مت
حته التخبل اهم 100 مره من اي حاجه بتحصل
انك تقبل
ت من بره انت عايز تتعلم هو وعرفت تتصرف
معك دلوقتي دخلت حاسس ان الجيش بتاعتك
مجرد ما تقبلها هتبتدي تفهم انا هتعامل
معاه ازاي لان وانت مش
انت اصلا رفض الموضوع
وكل ما هترفضه كل ما هينسى كل ما
بيقرب
من كل ما بتخ
بر انا هنا انا هعمل احسن الاداء
مش مهم بحبه ما
بحبه واقعد اقول
الاقي الموقف
علشان او شهر او سنه
او سنه فكانت
بتيجي عشان مش قادر اصلا اقول ماشي
مش قادر اقول
ان
انا قادر ابقى عملت
مشاكل
كل ما
حل هي كده وعدت ما قصرتش نفسي
شوف كل حاجه في حياتك
نشوف كل حاجه بنقول عليها لا انا مش
عايزها وعكسها عشان تعرف تحققها يعني
ما تشتغلش بالعكس
[موسيقى]
شويه
مش عايز
يحصل
اللي هو انا خايف اشرف
انا عندي جوه
في الاخر نجحت فعلا
خمس دقايق
وعايز اتعلم وانا في الطريق
دوت
اديني
خذ الرحله مبسوط